il ya en quel est votre niveau de
confiance aujourd'hui quant à la
sécurité des usines des chantiers pour
la reprise des activités par écouter
ondes est relativement confiant pour la
bonne et simple raison qu'on avait de
notre côté les organisations syndicales
on voulait que ça se fasse qu'on soit
viser assez tôt la reprise des
différents secteurs dans différentes
régions qui ont été vidés à cette eau
dans le but préparer justement les
chantiers quand c'est des chantiers de
construction mais le travail effectué
on a été abusée à cet os 2 3 semaines à
l'avance donc ces liens se pose pas la
dernière minute donc on était capable
avec les patrons et la csst les
autorités gouvernementales de faire des
trous dans le but de permettre à chaque
secteur d'avoir ses consignes et de
pouvoir pouvant démarrer en toute
sécurité pour les travailleurs et les
travailleuses
est ce qu'il y a une part de risques
pour les travailleurs
écoutez oui a toujours une part de
risque vous savez on va devoir apprendre
habib avec celui de cela malheureusement
un petit gars et il n'y aura pas non
plus de remettre d'avoir vous c'était
impensable n'ont vu qu'on soit confinée
pendant six mois
il faut donc défi qu'on avait pour les
travailleurs des travailleurs les lieux
de travail
c'était que ça puisse reprendre en toute
sécurité et en toute sécurité
ça devrait s'en prendre aux joueurs de
distanciation sociale donc le fable 2
distance entre les travailleurs et des
travailleuses la possibilité mais aussi
de se laver les mains avec de l'eau et
du savon le plus régulièrement possible
s'ils l'avaient important quand la
distanciation social n'est pas possible
mais ça prend des équipements de
protection individuelle dégâts des
masques des visières est également une
formation qui vient avec ça parce que
c'est pas donné à tout le monde blog
d'utiliser ses effets sur l'échantillon
n'est capable de tout faire ça devant
création physique mesures sanitaires
bah écoutez là on a une pratique les
chantiers résidentiels ont débuté ont
débuté de trois semaines depuis
ça va bien ça va bien au moment où on se
parle je voudrais qu'il ya peut-être eu
un petit relâchement au début de la
semaine passée mais ça c'est tout à fait
normal on s'habitue avec lui en revient
aux vieilles habitudes
donc je pense qu'il faut répéter les
consignes c'est éminemment important un
collègue de travail des hausses il
envoya doit voir ce que ces conseils ne
soient respectés il faut les répéter il
faut il faut les respecter parce que
c'est éminemment important c'est que ce
bien lui cela est très contagieux donc
si on veut si on veut poursuivre les
activités connect et n'a pas être
confinée à nouveau c'est très important
qu'on respecte les conseillers et c'est
ça qui nous a animés aussi tout au long
des travaux qu'on a menées dans le but
justement qui se passe en dehors en
pleine sécurité
il ya beaucoup de gens et surtout à
l'extérieur du québec je vous dirais
mais quand même des gens un peu partout
qui disent que le québec va pas mal vite
avec ce sont des confinement est ce que
vous partagez cette analyse écoutez se
pose pas à nous de décider quand on voit
des confiné cas remplacer ça appartient
à la santé à la santé publique les nous
devrait avoir un point de vue quand même
oui oui mais nous notre travail peu
important on savait qu'on était pour
revenir au travail
on m'a donné encore et toujours avec la
présence du virus
donc on se devait de merde de travailler
avec de travailler dans le but que ce
soit sécuritaire ont des travailleurs et
les travailleuses donc qu'on nous
aujourd'hui qu'on nous dans une semaine
dans six mois dans un an on avait le
même travail à faire c'est à dire de
permettre aux travailleurs et aux
travailleuses de faire tout ça en toute
sécurité
lyon lui fait on le fait on va commencer
en région en région on sait que c'est
moins problématique qui à montréal
bon la date du 25 mai à montréal
peut-être peut-être que le gouverneur
devra la réviser je sais pas parce que
c'est plus est ce que la normale à
partir de maintenant ce qu'on va
connaître dans les prochains mois franc
sorte qu'on sera moins rapide moins
productifs jusqu'à un certain point au
quotidien par exemple sur les chantiers
dans les usines selon vous ben moi je
pense que oui assurément
écoutez on est les champions on est dur
à parler justement
il faut pas qu'ils entrent en drama
repousse les travailleurs les plus
justement dans le but de respecter les
délais parce que ça va nécessairement
moins elliptique à main parce que on a
des logeurs de distanciation social à
garder au nord on aura se laver les
mains de façon régulière avec de l'eau
et du savon donc tout ça ça prend plus
de temps
bon faut essayer d'éviter de se croiser
rue donc ça prend plus de temps
puis on a des déclarations à faire
normalement quand on débute en quarts de
travail on devrait être déclarée à ce
qu'on a des symptômes parce que donc des
déclarations en taillant un peu plus
d'aucun plus d'administrations donc
activement la productivité devrait sans
trop sentir l'essence et pour votre
ligne tout le monde parce que on n'était
autre du tiff dans les normes nationales
ont lutté chaque oeil chez nous là un
mot sur la négociation avec le secteur
public samedi le président du conseil du
trésor christian dubé a dit on est prêt
et il le dit sur twitter à offrir une
bonification importante de rémunération
cotisable permanente aux préposés aux
bénéficiaires la ftq vous représentez
10000 préposés aux bénéficiaires d'un
secteur public la bonification
permanente de 12% pour les préposés
est ce que vous dites oui à ça écoutez
il faudrait qu'on me le propose aux
tables de négociation je viens
d'entendre je me suis levé j'ai parlé de
décoder son message de mai à date ça ne
transpire pas aux tables de négociation
ni à la notaire ce que j'ai entendu
monsieur tout le monde à csmc procès par
idées non plus à la table de la csn et
vous savez que moman en classe et ça
dans une entente globale au risque
qu'elles sont tous les jours une
augmentation de salaire est proposé il
faut que l'ensemble des travailleurs et
travailleuses maison de conditions de
travail qu'on veut leur imposer
donc ça s'est passé pour fait donc fi
les conditions ne sont pas acceptables
pour tout le monde
on va pas nécessairement approuvé le 12
pour fins de bonification permanente
pour les proposer c'est comme ça qu'il a
placé le gouvernement
c'est comme ça que la place et monsieur
dubé monsieur dubé à placer dans le
cadre d'une entente globale visant tout
le monde
c'est comme ça qu'est place et s'il n'y
a pas de juste parler des préposés qui a
dit oui les préposés
à condition qu'on s'entende pour tout le
monde l'écouté on attend des
propositions intéressantes pour qu'on
puisse combler pour tout le monde mais
comme je le dis même de 12%
d'augmentation dans les échelles
on n'a pas vu sa part être à la table
des négociations
on va suivre ça surveiller de près si ça
vient effectivement monsieur boyer
murphy parfait mais on se fait dire
merci